FEMALE SPEAKER: For our first
talk, Rodrigo, as I mentioned
is CEO of One Laptop
per Child.
And One Laptop per Child, which
many of you know about,
has been around for a few years
and its mission is to
empower the world's poorest
children through education.
So today Rodrigo will tell us
the success story of how One
Laptop has revolutionized
education through nonprofit
entrepreneurship.
And also unveil information
about the new Android tablet.
And how we can do our
part to help.
Please welcome Rodrigo
Arboleda.
RODRIGO ARBOLEDA: Thank you.
Well thank you Rachel.
And thank you everybody
for being here today.
My name is Rodrigo Arboleda.
And I'm the chairman and CEO
of One Laptop per Child
Association which is the
operating side for the One
Laptop per Child Foundation,
that has been run by my dear
classmate and old time friend,
Nicholas Negroponte, which you
probably know more about.
And I'm very happy to be here
because Google was one of our
original funders and
benefactors.
So this is a continuation of
an already existing story
between our two groups.
Let me be very rapid in trying
to reach to the end of the
idea that we have here.
So Joe then can talk about the
book and why the connection
between us, the book,
and you guys.
So let me tell you about the
genesis of this whole idea.
[INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]
[TWINKLE TWINKLE LITTLE STARS]
There was an original concept
that we had, not only to use
technology in education in third
world countries, but
also something that Nicholas
and I had been working
together for more than 31 years,
which is how to bring
peace through education
as well.
So that was used by some of the
very talented advertising
agency that had been working
with us on a pro bono basis,
as most of everybody that has
been working with us, in
trying to convey the message
that this is a mission.
And this is not a
market for us.
Children for us are a mission,
and not a market.
How did I get involved
with this?
Well I'm an architect
as a profession.
And I went to school with
Nicholas Negroponte
at MIT in the 1960s.
So we are both architects.
And I went back into practice
in the private world.
But 30 years ago I met with him
and we started the first
large scale project of education
at a distance, when
Nicholas and I went to my
country of origin, Columbia.
And developed what is considered
to be the most
important education at a
distance project ever done in
Latin America at that time.
It was 32 years ago.
And the final push for action
for me, which has prompted me
to continue all my life in the
current realm dedicated to
this project is, that I have
lost these three children of a
very rare disease.
Of a heart condition.
And my only concern right now
is how to leave the children
of the world a little bit of a
legacy that I hoped I could
have left for my
three children.
And therefore it's a combination
of a professional
friendship with Nicholas.
The dedication to study
and education.
And my personal family life.
How this whole thing started?
Believe it or not this whole
thing started for us when we
started looking at this in my
country of origin, Columbia.
In 1948 there was a very major
discovery or invention called
the transistor radio.
Well a priest in the forgotten
lands of the Altiplano of
Bogota, saw this little
invention and immediately saw
the connection between that
little gadget and technology.
And immediately put into every
peasant in the region.
At the end there were more than
four and a half million
peasants, a transistor radio in
the pocket of their shirts
while they were still plowing
the land with oxen and very
primitive ways.
And in order to that he created
a radio station that
was emblematic for 40 years
in Colombia, called Radio
Sutatenza, Radio Sutatenza.
It transmitted constantly,
while the
peasants and their wives--
were at home-- and the peasants
in the field,
constant programs on
how to improve the
conditions of the soil.
The conditions of
the household.
How to boil water, how to do the
most incredible primitive
ways that for us were
taken for granted.
But for them were nonexistent.
This priest educated four
and a half million
peasants in that way.
Alvin Toffler in his book,
"The Third Wave" and "The
Future Shock" visited
with him.
It was very important at that
time how to use technology in
education and improvement
of social conditions.
The pedagogical side is
these two gentlemen.
It's Jean Piaget from
Switzerland.
And our own Seymour Papert,
South African mathematician
who went to MIT in 1967 after
having worked with Jean Piaget
for 15 years.
And they saw that people that
wrote code or programs
developed something, that for
you might be taken for granted
right now, a very special
condition of the brain.
And that people who wrote
code could have a better
understanding of critical
thinking.
Of solution oriented
mentality.
Of sharing.
And of reflection.
Those four issues were
very important.
So Seymour in 1967 arrives at
MIT to start the Artificial
Intelligence Lab.
And he has the honesty and the
audacity of telling that every
child in the future should have
a computer and be able to
write code.
At that time the computer was
larger than this building.
Everybody thought that
this guy was crazy.
But Nicholas saw him, when
Nicholas was already after
graduating from architecture,
and told him listen, far from
believing that you're crazy
what I think that you are
doing is great.
Because what I'm trying to do
is create a graphical user
interface for us,
poor architects.
That we're the last architects
that are still working with
square Ts and triangles.
And pencils.
So they got together and that
became an association that
lasted for almost 40 years
because Seymour now is almost
90 years of age.
And that's with Nicholas at one
of the last meetings that
they were together.
And so that prompted us to say,
we need to do something.
We need to try to bring the
new technologies into
educations in similar fashion,
as the transistor radio and
radio station were brought
at the time in 1948.
And it is not difficult to
understand because if you take
into consideration that the
transistor radio of the time
is today a laptop.
And a radio station of that
time, today is the internet.
Then immediately you can see
the similarities and the
symbolisms that are present
in this type of concept.
So we didn't invent anything.
We just tried to advance a
concept that we knew had
worked very well for four and
a half million peasants.
And try to scale it
up to the rest of
the developing nations.
So we needed to then decide
that we needed to
differentiate learning
from education.
Education is one thing.
It's the accumulation of
a lot of knowledge.
Probably sometimes encyclopedic
knowledge.
But is many times or most of
the times, still after 150
years of Industrial Revolution,
is still is a very
active person, which is the
teacher, and a very passive
person, which is the student,
listening to what they're
talking about.
Learning is about taking into
your own hands more the
destiny, and being the architect
of your own destiny.
And if you do that from the very
beginning, we can really
accomplish tremendous
miracles.
And in order to do that writing
code is, I shouldn't
be talking about this to you
guys, but writing code for the
rest of the world is not
understood yet as a basic
element of learning.
And also programming and
constructionism, what we then
develop after the basic concept
of writing code, how a
child of five years of age,
could build his own knowledge
base by building, by doing.
And that's when Seymour came
up with this already well
known application called the
Logo language, which is a
language that allows a child of
five years of age to write
code in linear programming.
Something that for us, the
pre-generation, required for
us to have known algebra, then
calculus, and then physics.
Nowadays with that language
this could be done.
This was written in 1980.
And has been the basic element
of our pedagogical ideas.
And that is embedded now in
three iterations which is
called Scratch, is called EToys
and TurtleArt, depending
on the age and the complexity
of the child
that is using them.
But these are the cornerstone
of our
entire pedagogical element.
Then we started in 1982
in three countries.
We started in Colombia
as you saw before.
When Nicholas working in
France with President
Mitterand, [INAUDIBLE]
creating what was called at
the time the [INAUDIBLE].
It was a pioneer work
in trying to get
children to use computers.
And then we went to Senegal,
in Africa.
And then we went to
Pakistan, in Asia.
And that has been the most
important element of the
experience that we have had.
Then in 2001 in Cambodia,
Nicholas and his family-- his
son and his former wife--
saw this little village that has
been very much published.
And you can see it in "60
Minutes" also, because there
was a big segment in "60
Minutes" about this little
village in which there was no
electricity, no telephone, no
running water, nothing.
And Nicholas took a big screen,
a satellite dish, and
he took a little generator.
And all these children
started--
and the first word that they
learned how to say was Google.
That was very important because
they immediately
started investigating Google.
And that was one of the ideas
that Nicholas brought to
Sergey and Larry.
And that's how they became
involved with us
five years later on.
This is a school nowadays
that is emblematic.
There are five of them
right now in Cambodia
in very remote villages.
And you should take a look
at their websites in "60
Minutes."
So that idea in Cambodia gave
birth to our idea that if this
is working in Cambodia, it
should work worldwide.
And the blocking element was the
lack of access of a child
to computational capacity at
prices they could afford.
At that time a laptop
was over a $1,000.
And we thought that we should
reduce at least to 1/10 the
value of a laptop, in order to
be able to really go to the
base of the pyramid.
So that's how the famous, or
infamous, name of the $100
laptop came to be.
It was not that we had already
designed the laptop.
It was that that was the order
of magnitude that we thought
was needed in order to really
be able to break the barrier
between massive scaling
of access to
computational capacity.
And not being able to do so.
And also because then in 2005,
Internet was becoming really
more ubiquitous.
And it was not, as we did 35
years ago which was very
rudimentary--
telephone lines--
that took forever to
transmit words.
Then Nicholas presented these
with Kofi Annan of the United
Nations, at the ITU
meeting in Libya.
And it became an instant success
in terms of concept.
The concept was so powerful.
Curiously enough it was more
powerful because of the little
yellow crank, than
anything else.
But that would remain.
Because we can charge the
battery with a crank, as the
radios in South Africa do.
But it was such a thing that
everybody became enchanted.
And many presidents
of countries
started to talk to us.
And then we decided
to launch it.
So what have we done?
We converted a crisis into
opportunities because of the
problems that we faced in those
areas of the world.
And this is the computer
at that
time, as what was presented.
But this is the computer of
today, as you know very well,
because you have seen it
all over the place.
When you see a photo like this
you understand that something
transformational has happened
to the mind of a child.
When you see the amount of
concentration, when you see
the amount of devotion, and the
amount of time that they
play today, and again this is
seven years ago, you might
think that this is obvious
because of the iPads, and the
Nexus, and the other tablets
that we have in place.
But at that time it was
unbelievable for a person to
understand how much these could
be an attractive element
of learning.
We end the isolation as well.
I mean the child in a remote
village could become connected
and learn and experiment and
enjoy and play and do.
And this is in the remote
villages of Peru in the
mountains where a child was
teaching the grandparent how
to read and write.
So it became a child-centric
approach and the children
became the agents of change.
We have been educated that we
are the ones who embed in the
children the change.
In this capacity the empowerment
of the child
became so obvious, that
now we base the
change in their shoulders.
This is in Bogota, with
Shakira, the singer.
All of her schools are
with our laptops.
And this is in a little
remote shanty town.
And in this little place in
which there's no place even
for the clothes, there
are two children and
each child has a laptop.
We have delivered already two
and a half million laptops in
41 countries and 21 languages.
And this is in Nepal.
And this is in Peru.
And every place we go, this is
the environment that we see.
This is a real movement
and a revolution.
And this is in India.
This teacher, before their
computer arrived, used to
teach in a very orthodox
manner.
The children were all
sitting in a row.
They could not raise their
hands to talk.
If they raised their hand at
the wrong time, the teacher
will come with a stick
and hit them.
And the computer arrived and
pandemonium arrived.
And the teacher the next day was
teaching in this fashion,
and he thought I had never been
in my life more alive.
And more feeling a contribution
to the children's
education than when they
come in the morning.
And I go home every afternoon
saying, I need
to prepare for tomorrow.
Because tomorrow they're
going to be
asking me so many questions.
There are going to be so many
involved, that I better be
sharp in what I'm going
to answer to them.
This is near Bombay.
This is about a week ago
or two weeks ago.
You guys have given a prize to
a Sugar Labs kid of 14 years
of age, Augustine, in Uruguay
where we have 700,000 kids
with a computer.
Every child in Uruguay in
primary school age, including
autistic children, including
Down Syndrome children,
including visually impaired
children, and including
physically impaired children
has one of our laptops.
Connected to the Internet.
It is the first country in the
world in which something like
this is happening.
It is the most important
educational
laboratory in the world.
And you guys have something
to do with it.
And you should be very proud
of what has happened there.
Well if this guy, which is a
14-year-old hacker, and you
guys are giving him a prize and
you're going to bring him
over here to California, and
this happened to him.
Can you imagine what could have
happened to the other
700,000 children that
are in Uruguay?
Or to the [? 900 ?]
children that are in Peru?
Or to the other 220,000 that we
have in Rwanda in Africa,
with a computer connected
to the Internet?
This is the challenge and this
is where the synergies between
what you guys do and what we
do, could become important.
Let me show you this one also.
Another film.
This is in Peru.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
RODRIGO ARBOLEDA [OFFSCREEN]:
He won a prize.
And Robert Redford brought
him to Sundance.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
RODRIGO ARBOLEDA [OFFSCREEN]:
Because of what he did
changing the life of a child.
The teacher went with him.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
RODRIGO ARBOLEDA: So these two
examples, Augustine and this
kid, give you a living
testimony of
what this is all about.
We have not a computer
project.
We are a social equality
project and change the
paradigm of the education
project.
That's exactly what we are.
And this is what had
happened until now.
I want to show you where we are
right now because this has
to do also a lot with you.
Until now we have been
working in Linux.
And the Sugar environment which
is the user interface,
and is nowadays adopted
worldwide.
And it is understood and
accepted that it is becoming
the standard of which education
should be all about.
A one to one.
But we are developing a tablet
that is all Android based.
And even more we are now porting
our Sugar environment
into Android.
And this is one of the reasons
why we are here today is
because the opportunities for
synergies that could be
developed among us.
This is coming now in
about two months.
And Walmart is going to
be introducing it.
For the first time we are
coming to the States.
We have done it in two stages.
We went to two slums in
Miami, where I live.
In Liberty City, because there
are pockets of ignorance,
violence, and ignorance.
In Miami or in any other city of
the United States, equally
bad as many countries
that we find in
the third world countries.
And therefore we should have
charity start at home.
So I was able to convince
Nicholas that although this
was originally intended for
third world countries, there
should be something that we can
contribute here in the States.
So what we are doing right now
is launching a massive
approach of how to bring to
children of fiive years to 12
years old, now with tablets from
three years to 12 years,
an educational tablet that
could be of use to them.
And this is going to be called
Build Your Own Dreams.
And this is all Android.
And it is all dedicated to
inspire children and to use
the constructionist approach
to learning in the most
important fashion that we can.
And this is going to
have all the books.
And this is all designed by the
same team that designed
our laptop, which is Yves
Behar, a group here.
Fuse Project in San Francisco.
For which even our laptop right
now is in the permanent
collection of the Museum
of Modern Art.
Here in San Francisco,
and the Museum of
Modern Art in New York.
This is the actual tablet and
this is where we are now
trying to combine the worlds
of Linux, Android,
portability, and low price.
Because these will come
at a much lower
price than the laptop.
And then I wanted to give you a
very brief glimpse before I
give Joe the opportunity to
round up why we are here
today, is our next long
term development.
Nicholas has just been named
Chairman of a very interesting
project which is the X-Prize
project that you guys are
involved with, because of
this particular project.
It just happened that we are
interested in children that
had no opportunity whatsoever
to know how to read.
When they are 30 kilometres away
from the nearest school.
And where nobody in their
communities or villages know
how to read.
And we think that there are
between 60 million and 100
million of these children
worldwide.
So we went and looked around and
we found in Ethiopia this
community in the crater of a
volcano up in the mountains of
4,000 meters high up.
And we distributed, together
with Sugata Mitra--
which you already
know as well--
on the Hole in the Wall
project in India.
And together with this lady by
the name of Maryanne Wolf from
Tufts University who dedicated
her life to study autism.
And through that she started
to understand when mankind
learned how to read.
When you pass from a very
graphic description of the
Egyptians' hieroglyphics to the
very abstract writing of
cuneiform writing code
of the Assyrians.
When that happened?
She discovers and she explains
in her book.
The size of the brain
increased in about a
millennium or two from about
600 grams to 1,000 grams.
So the brain had to create an
enormous amount of cells in
order to be able to understand
the passage from a figurative
environment to an abstract
environment.
So together with these two
gentlemen, a lady and
gentleman, we have launched
this project.
And this is--
unfortunately it's too
dark for this one--
these are the villages
in Ethiopia.
And we about eight months ago
started a project in two
villages with 23 computers.
These are Motorola laptops,
not computers but tablets.
This is the environment.
This is the type of village.
There is no electricity,
no sign.
The only words that we were able
to find were some of the
clothes that had the
Adidas name.
Or whatever type of description
that came in the clothing.
Nobody in the communities
learned how to read or write.
They had never seen a sign.
And the only thing that we
installed was a solar panel to
charge the batteries that every
night charged the computers.
The tablets.
And these are Motorola
tablets.
And we gave the boxes
to the children.
And 10 minutes later everybody
has un-boxed the tablets.
15 minutes later on they
knew how to turn it on.
Two days later on they were
already exploring.
And the whole thing was so
incredible that even a month
and a half later on we have not
put the video camera to
use because we were afraid that
they were going to start
streaming video.
And they hacked the tablet and
they put the camera to work.
I mean, nobody knew
how to do it.
And that's when the tipping
point came to us.
This is something again
transformational.
And this is something that
we should look around.
And that's when Nicholas about a
month ago came and talked to
Larry and Sergey.
And in that group together
with other companies they
created the X-Prize.
And they are now putting $10
million to develop a project
in the next two years of the
most innovative way of
teaching or learning
how to read.
Because if you learn
how to read, then
you read how to learn.
There's a tipping point about
seven or eight years of age in
which, if you have learned how
to read, then you can use that
reading expertise into
reading how to learn.
And that's where we
are interested in.
And that's the frontier in
which we want to advance.
And this is the type of
environments that you can see.
Together they are working.
This particular photograph
is very important.
Look at what is happening
here.
This kid is looking at
this other kid work.
This kid is looking
at this other one.
Then you have one that
is sort of the
supervisor or the teacher.
And this is complete environment
self-created by
them, in terms of how a complete
village can really
take into their own hands,
something that until then was
absolutely not existent.
So a few weeks later on if you
could see, they were already
doing the alphabet.
And they were already writing
in the floor.
They learned.
They were already singing the
alphabet, A-B-C-D-E-F. And
they are now really giving us
the first glimpse that indeed
a child could really
learn how to read.
And if we prove that in the
next couple of years, this
will be as transformational
as the entire element from
Gutenberg printing stage.
This could be a transformational
element.
Because until now we have been
told that you need a teacher
to tell you how to read.
So I'm finalizing here with
just why I am here.
I gave you the history.
Well number one.
I met Joe in Mexico.
And we are trying
to work a lot in
Mexico and Latin America.
But evidently the commercial
entities, like the Microsofts
and all the similar guys,
are not very happy.
Because we use Linux and we want
to have it free and we
want to have open source.
And we are trying to advocate
all of the things that are not
very commercial for them.
And what I can ask you today is
for you to leave with, and
what Joe is going to tell
you about, is how
can we again re-engage?
You were together with
us seven years ago.
It was transformational.
Then we became perhaps too
mundane for the Google
stratospheric type of things.
But now we have a proof
of concept.
Now we have shown that this can
be done and then we have
seen a new frontier
that comes up.
And the new frontier is how
on earth can we scale up?
How we can really pass from
the two and a half million
laptops to the 200
million laptops.
To the 100 million laptops.
Because otherwise an entire
generation of children, ages
five and more, will remain in
the same obscurantism of the
medieval area in which
they were born.
And their family were born.
How to create synergy?
How can we work together with
the group that encompasses the
Google family, and the Android
developments, and so forth?
And for that I'm very thankful
that Joe, very generously, all
of the royalties of his book
are going to be given as a
contribution to OLPC.
And that's one reason that I
wanted to be here with him
today because that is the type
of a spirit of a mission like
this that is surpassing any
commercial or any element of
mercantilism that we might
think of as the
other people do.
And without any further ado,
what I would like to suggest
to you guys is, help us.
Tell us.
Write to us.
Think about it.
How we can really help hundreds
of millions of
children take advantage of
technology into their education.
There's my email address.
And feel free to
suggest ideas.
We need your help.
Because otherwise we will
just remain on a two
million or ten million.
And that's not what we
were created for.
Without any further ado, I would
like to ask Joe to give
you a glimpse of what
he's got going on.
And thank you very much for
your attending to me.